Please help me welcome to the stage, Andrew Lincoln
Chandler Riggs
Steven Yeun
Christian Serrano's Josh McDermitt
Norman Reed
yeah
and last but not least jeffrey dean
morgan
are we pissing our pants yet
you mother fuckers
you can breathe you can blink you can
walk in cry
I would oh hell you're all going to be
doing that or you can lead us on a
little moderation
all right all right listen if it was me
who got it in the end I think people
will be fine with that
this has been an amazing
I will say one thing about that's
happened over the summer that I have not
seen happen after previous seasons which
is this in this incredible sense of
community around that even in the last
panel some guy said Houdini can kill
I was in a remote part of California and
this old this guy a barber outside the
shop this old guy was walking across the
street
never would have thought to say hi to
the guy and he shouted across the street
I think it's gland or whatever and it's
just like this is that we're all
everyone's speculating and people are
asking
huh well what's it been like for you to
be a become a part of this fandom to
become a part of this community I think
I've been kind of living in this bubble
in Georgia I mean I've only been on the
show for about 12 minutes thus far
army and then kind of went to work but
I've never
I was in New York when the first episode
that you'll see me aired in 16 i guess
or last year
uh and I've never been stopped so much
in my life ever
and I'm getting a little bit of a feel
for it though we haven't started airing
yet I hang out with the cast as the cast
that shall not be named
yeah just the cast and people wherever
you are and we're kind of in the middle
of nowhere in Georgia but you can go
somewhere
and people like come out of the floor
and ceilings and walls that you didn't
know were there you think you're kind of
alone and and converge upon the cast
it's amazing it's amazing and the fans
have been nothing but also mad as well
as everyone uses he's sitting up here
well this I mean I really you know to
see what's happened with walking dead
and having been there almost from the
beginning it's been an incredible thing
to watch one of the most significant
speed experiences to be even close to
what you are now forever you are part of
this community and you're part of this
world
it's cool because I've always been a fan
of the shows and started as well as a
comic book so then to step in
in this role in particular in with these
people has been nothing short of awesome
Scott can you talk a little about the
new locations and some of the new
characters and some of the stuff that
we're going to see in season seven
well there's Karen haha what you guys
got a lot of time you saw King is
Ezekiel there
yeah yeah there is there is that is
Carrie Payton who is a remarkable actor
and I you know he's a bit younger than
his heel is in the book is bit more
svelte
but he came in and he owned it and the
most important thing is when I showed
his audition - Robert Robert went
bananas
he's fantastic i think people are going
to them excellent let's start talking to
Castle start with the mr. Andrew Lincoln
this entire this entire the last half of
the season every episode as an audience
member i'm going all man don't go in and
kill us all
you know it's just like there was so
much hubris and so much like oh we we
rule everything we can take care
everything so can you describe a little
bit
what it was like shooting the final
scene of last last season when it sucked
obviously and you know the funny thing
was my my mom who's become a really kind
of weirdly superfan she's always on the
internet checking out the show and she
just had dinner before I
I came out and she said you know you've
got to get back to that space you rat
at the end of last year haha and I said
well what do you mean is that where you
gotta dig deep
seriously committed and your face man
you were terrified you were sleeping you
were like a child you would
it was and I said are you giving me
acting notes and even my wife just went
really
come on Laura pipe down you know but yes
so it was it was a pretty intense return
you know after having a hiatus and so
chillin in my orchard to come back and
see his face
it can I just point out that he's having
way too much fun playing this dude and
but look i'm not going to talk about it
I i I'm we made it I spoke about this
before and I'll say it again is that we
all linked arms
it's it's a really shitty start to the
season but hang in there guys I know you
will because we're we're heading towards
i think one of the graces showdowns that
we've had in this show since terminus
so hang in there with us I know you will
Stevie on who I know read the comics
before you have been a fan of comments
for the show and we we talked a lot
about it when she 100 camp and we talked
about this point of the story and now
here we are at this point in the story
so how has this felt for you and what
did it
what did it feel like reaching this part
I've always been a huge fan of the
comics in
I remember that particular issue
my cousin called me and he was like yo
Glen's got it too good right now
hundreds coming out i don't know what's
going to happen
and obviously after a hundred came out I
was like oh crap
but it was it was an oh crap but it was
also this amazing like this is
incredible to be a hundred issues in and
to land a bomb like this to propel it
forward was so incredible and for me as
a fan I was like this moment is iconic
and however it happens it's it's such a
great moment
and when we led up to it to see you know
all the components that were happening
and to see me in the flesh is awesome
- to know that from here on out that
there's going to be an opening to just
thrust the show even further and for me
as a fan and as a participant like it's
it's probably one of the coolest things
ever
lauren cohan you Maggie is Maggie's
having a severe medical crisis when we
left off and and on top of the fact that
she's kneeling in front of negan and is
probably as conscious and she can be at
this point knows something really
terrible is going to happen so what
what is the preparation like with with
that kind of had that layered tragedy
yeah um you know it's funny this show
gives us this opportunity to go to such
visceral places and this episode that
episode for all of us was one of the
most physically and emotionally
demanding things i mean i was actually
reflecting on and just thinking I love
ross and sonequa and Michael for
carrying me on that stretch of the day 7
days and it
it was you know we we had a really good
time and Andy and it was when you see
that purple exhausted makeup and you
I don't know for two weeks or so we were
sort of in that state and it was just a
Reedy a really crazy thing I just I'm
just like sitting up here with everybody
just thinking how lucky we are to be you
know you don't act anything you get to
go to the creative space and obviously
I'm don't have the illness maggie has in
there but we we get to be together and
like go to physical crazy and
emotionally crazy places and we do that
together
I don't know i'm not in a bit of an
emotional tension here but you get me
yeah yeah
you don't you don't have that illness
though I don't I i did think about when
i had my appendix taken out
I had two days where my mom was like
you're fine
you need to go to the bathroom you're
fine you're fine and then I got to the
hospital and they were like wow you were
about to die if he should be good so
they take our index so I channeled a
little bit of that but I mostly just um
you know that I think that episode what
so many of us have experiences that
guilt like is is the choice that
character made responsible for getting
us to that to the end of meetings bat or
to the situation and Maggie definitely
you know it was so you know feeling the
need to protect Chandler this scene for
you with the end I mean it
he's car was really trying to grow up
he's had to grow up really fast and now
he is
sounds 1i and so yours you're kneeling
and you have this patch on your eye
so what how is that as a performer like
to to be acting basically with a patch
of what was the experience like I mean
depth perception is my biggest loss
there it's so annoying it's like there's
like a bug
I can't tell if it's like right here or
look like you're just like squatting and
like all the way over there but I was
just your natural tick
did you know that they're not crazy
no but how many i don't know i mean it's
I i actually enjoyed wearing the
prosthetic and episode 9 a lot more than
I didn't enjoy wearing the bandage just
because the bandage
they always want like they always want
to see my eyebrows they have to
constantly push it up and then like
pulled down on this side and after every
take we have to be adjusted versus the
prosthetic is just like now we're
putting on and it looks really cool too
so it's too light lot more chill and
easy but yeah you don't realize how much
like vision you lose like it it's like a
good 70 degrees of vision that is like
completely gone like remember Norman
tapping on my like constantly tapping on
my other shoulder and I'd be like see I
deny
I'd love to talk about really quickly
your machine has had such an incredible
she was this reclusive Warrior when we
saw her she was very closed off then she
started to open up she was kind of
reborn and now we're actually seeing the
most human complex and romantic side of
her so can you talk a little bit about
the vulnerability between Rick and
Michonne I yeah it was interesting
because I was you know I was thinking
about this question and I was the moment
I feel where her vulnerability really
started to open up specifically towards
Rick actually i think was a really long
time ago I was episode of the episode
entitled clear which was also written by
mr. Scott Gimple over there and I'm
really was this moment i think where she
not only bonds with his son in a way
that is really reviving for her and
opens her up and allows her to start
putting down all those layers and all
the all that armor just begin to go
there in terms of you know investing in
a young life and in seeing his light and
and having an empathy and sympathy for
this young men in this world and and
knowing what it is like to be a mother
and and wanting to be there for him and
so and his acceptance of her by the end
of the episode is really opens up her
heart but everything I think connected
to Rick and Michonne connected with Carl
to at times because it's kind of like he
accepts her first and then there's this
big moments between a recommendation in
that episode that to me
there's one in particular that for me
that day that we shot it I was like me
he's gonna see him that way one day
which was the moment in uh it was in the
jail cell when we're looking for bullets
and ammo and there's not it was and they
will devise plan and
Michonne does not call them out for this
but he kind of thinks she is
she hands him the one bullet but she did
find and and he kind of snapped at her
and her responses
you know I don't have a problem with
that and it was so funny when we shot it
was the crew is the crew that one set
they all I looked over to mr. Gimbel
finally because he was their course and
they were like to get together and I was
like I was like huh
and and I don't know I don't know what
it was but they look at that moment I
thought that makes sense actually
because at this
for her it made sense to me because she
is a woman who has to deeply respect the
man she opens up to and that she was
already developing such a respect from
him the way she treated him versus the
way she treated the governor she could
see he was such a like he was a good man
burdened with leadership vs he needed
leadership to feel like a man
so there was something about that
connect that realization seeing him like
that and seeing his brokenness and his
pain and things that she could connect
to that we're making her put down her
mess and and open up more so that sort
of journey if you know did I think it's
awesome it took as long as it did
because it developed a very complex
connection arm and allowed her to work
through her several wounds and an armory
well obviously a Rick's other
significant romantic relationship is
Darrell and Norman now I believe you
brought a video to illustrate this and
I'm I'm terrified of what's about to
happen i I'm like I'm on pins and
needles um yet let this is what happened
for it started off we went to Tokyo and
I we were super tired and
with jet lags and sitting there and and
early in the morning and and he goes you
speak a little Japanese not you know
yeah and he goes
how do you say thank you for having me
in your country
I didn't do the hand movements yeah I
did and so I said toilet water doko
deska and he goes how I got a toy while
doko deska then he goes wait before we
start toilet wha
doko deska and I didn't do they're
looking at him like what
and then he goes toilet a 100k desk and
he goes what did I just say
and I said where's the toilet but
there's that they're not going Frank
language
I I think something about the fallout of
this guy huh but arm and then I put
chickens in his trailer
one day and then I came back from having
my windows tinted on my truck it's in
it's at andy's b.i.t.c.h across the
front when I was a really good right
yeah very much
and then we had a Transpo for that and
then we had been in one setting i get a
package and I open it and glitter
explodes in my face and nose huh yeah
and then what happened next
the worst thing about that is that that
is such a mean prank that stuff that is
what glitters like clown herpes-like it
does not know it doesn't matter it never
goes away
absolutely right i do in a year would be
like it's taking my IRA I drove home
from that point and there were people at
red lights look into me like I was you
know I could been clubbing or her in to
a club you know what I'm saying
and then I went into acting I'm gonna
have to before i go home and getting
humiliated
I kind of want to and vacuum that thing
are you know it took me 25 minutes and I
was beating up with sweat and all the
rest i got back in the car and I cranked
up the hair coming again it just went
dark
my sweaty face and then I went to the
coffee shop and they said you've got
something in your hairline
now they're calling me sparkles and
glitter boy I used to be somebody in my
own hometown
huh and and and when I got on the plane
to go to San Diego my two children had
tears in their eyes and they said what
didn't any Norman do it and I said
sweethearts
he's he's humiliated your father and
international scale and they said what
can we do
and that's so believe me with it this is
the end right there
it's in your beard here oh that could
not back by oh oh dear
ya hear you
oh look like a crazy prospect I didn't
go quite the way I wanted it and I was
an innocent by
yeah well I got a trade the game of
thrones people are gonna look fabulous
I think we're looking forward to eat it
backfire
that was that was the most amazing
let you down my channel follow followed
by daddy
good news want to go to your house looks
like and it looks like you've been doing
filthy things at the circus excited for
the glitter tater ship of season seven
year
you're never gonna get that out let's do
that thing that is you know
next question Chris huh I want to I crap
i want to welcome Josh McDermitt this is
his first san diego comic-con
yeah I do and I'm doing good this is fun
have you seen have you seen the eugene
cosplayers have you seen some mutant
cosplayers
I've seen a lot of eugene cosplay so I
feel like you know guys dress up as
Eugene that's to be expected i get it
maybe you don't have the body to be
Darryl it
that's fine but I'm starting to see a
lot of female Eugene's awesome because i
think they have the long hair so they
can kind of put it into a mullet easily
and in that sort of thing but I look at
them and it's like I don't want to sleep
with you gene
I don't know you know it's I've never
really pictured Eugene is a sex symbol
so if if i don't get killed off Scott
Campbell i would love to explore that
storyline
it's fun you know the thing is like they
get the attention as to go to the
details right
they have to I'm seeing cosplay for
Eugene where they've set up a bookshelf
like from Episode five season five
reunion was spying on Rosita and Abraham
having sexy time
yeah and the walk around like a
makeshift bookshelf that they're just
creeping like that's genius i love you
apple is awesome michael cudlitz it
that's sort of where they sat in between
your ex-girlfriend your current
girlfriend that's very strange dynamics
kind of awesome
he planned it that way and the man you
want to be with what
what was that it like what what was that
experience for him what was this
epiphany that he had in the last you
know it last season
well I think it's win-win
uh-huh teru teru to read
no I think that look early on i think
that both both Abraham and Rosie two
found each other and it became a
relationship of convenience if you
follow the graphic novel
Rosita used her looks to get to kind of
to survive early on my way in her way
the way and after she met Abraham
Abraham was the only person that she had
met that didn't want anything from her
physically that actually did connect
with her as a human and he taught her
how to be a soldier
which he excelled at so I think that for
the two of them
it just made sense at the time now that
I think Abraham sees a tomorrow and
tomorrow after tomorrow
he can't deny what his heart is feeling
so it's not convenient anymore it's it's
actual practicality and he finds
a lot of things that he just admires in
Sasha to be those things that he has
always held important in his life that
she already possesses will to survive
strength intelligence beauty and he
wants to share that were there any and
as hard as it is because i think he
still loves Rosita would do anything for
Rosita and or Eugene because they are
they're his family
there comes a point where you can't deny
what you're feeling and this is it a
time in the story where he is allowed to
feel and he's reminded that there are
things that are worth not only dying for
a living for
and I was that in her at that was
masterful
I don't know how you pulled that up
because I think there are a lot of women
the on it's like you son of a bit and
now everyone's crying and equal what was
it like working so closely with cutlets
this past season
it was it was so much fun he and I have
a lot of fun together a lot of jokes a
lot of it was a lot of good times and we
broke down a few barriers to because we
spend a lot of time in that car and uh
you know it got all the way it got real
you know he had to help me with my
breast milk couple times
I'm you know I was still nursing so I'm
pumping every couple of hours but we
cooked up in this card and he's like no
no give it give it to me I got it I got
it I'll take it to the cashier
I'll take it I think I got it I got it I
I know what this is about
I got I got you know that the coffee is
that the whole and so you know it was it
was such a such a great connection you
know so he's such a gentleman and he was
so it was very brotherly and sisterly he
was you know taking taking great care
and i would go well yeah he's a dad
I take it take it yet thanked you in the
cooler
yeah thank you so so that was cool but
yeah a lot of good conversation lot of
good times we had learned a lot too
because you know obviously this man he's
been at it for a long time a lot to
learn from him
so it was great this is also christian
serratos his first time at san diego
comic-con
what nervous this is so intimidating
there's so many of you know it's michael
michael help her with her breast milk
yeah but it's not intimidated because
these people waited like they're here to
see you like they wanted their it's not
like they're holding their arms like you
better win us over like there and I want
to be charming and you want to be funny
and i happen to think I'm very funny so
I'm nervous like you have to give me
pity laughs if I'm not uh huh
what what's been removed
touch me
Christian Christian yeah listen Josh
really jealous right now
what's been rewarding for you for
Rosita's arc so much on
first of all just getting to work with
all these people coming in you know
after the show has been established and
and and coming in when I did was a
little nerve-racking you want to make
sure that you do a good job and and you
hear so many great things about the show
and you just want to like performing and
you want to bond and
and I had heard so many great things
about the cast and their work ethic and
and I was just really excited that they
all took me in and I was able to learn
so much from everybody
I mean even just in the last episode of
season six I feel like you know we're
all such good friends and we all trust
each other so much but to be able to go
through that last episode with everyone
was such an incredible bonding
experience
I really feel like I I grew as an actor
that's going to be a pivotal moment for
me for a long long time and that doesn't
happen when you can't trust the people
you're with
it just cannot so so it was really
exciting for me to be here for however
long i'm here and just know that I've
had this moment and even things like
Josh was talking about like cosplay
that is so exciting for me I mean I'm
just like everybody else I get excited
about TV shows and and cool fun
interesting things so to see people
dressed up as a character I'm portraying
is such like a nerdy exciting thing for
me i love it so much
even when it's a guy even when it's a
guy even when Michael does it I get so
excited
haha the closer a little tight but
there's there's there's a few like
letting a comic book characters that are
written but not many that have been you
know put on a big screen or small screen
so it's just really exciting for me that
I see so many lesbians come up to me and
say how excited they are to have a
really strong mind that they could rest
up bad
so that makes me really proud and I hope
that I you know get to keep the training
this really strong woman for her as long
as I can
I think that was very well done
Christians around the crop Ross Marquand
if you don't know is an amazing
impressionist &
we've tried to get can you just quickly
do I i know you could use to hear
support for like a quick second
just you know what Chris I'm tired your
poor your horse crap
you're always getting me up here doing
the Harrison Ford and all this
I'm over it all right get off of my
panel
what else does that happen on the
satellite
are you able to do that on the sentiment
what's a good are you able to do that on
the set a ladder is it really serious
intense it was there sometimes we're
just doesn't make sense to be Jackie
obviously but I remember last season in
612 we were doing that the raid on the
compound and cutlets and seth killian
people don't know this but cuts does
amazing sylvester stallone and Seth
Gilliam does an amazing
robert de niro and i was playing Mick
was but merchants Meredith from rocky
and I was like come on you know you
gotta get in there you gotta give these
shady as hell
well we were good in there
you don't try to take half my stuff
you're not gonna do that out yet when we
just didn't have to stuff then we can
walk away
that rocks in your head come on I don't
know what you do looks like it worked up
I don't think they're going to kill all
of us might kill me when I can't stop
myself clear yellow and this will be
human
come on he'll try with show you you all
right